Teşekkürler Sesim geliyor Merhaba
hayal ettiğiniz Dünya nasıl bir yer
ben 3 yıl önce bir hayal kurdum hayal
ettiğim dünya daha Adil daha özgür daha
özenli
doğaya yakın daha kapsayıcı hoşgörülü
geçmişten aldığı kökleri ile iyimser bir
geleceğe uzanan bir dünyaydı
bu hayalin adı değil oldu
dilbigan Ben bir girişimciyim bir sosyal
girişimciyim
giyiyy ise moda markası
bana ne iş yaptığımı sorduklarında
ben şöyle cevap verebilirim giysi üretip
satıyorum
anlaşılır basit olur herhalde ama çok
eksik kalır
şöyle cevap versem Ne dersiniz
Ben hayal ettiğim dünya için çalışıyorum
acaba
işlerimize böyle bir bakış açısıyla
bakabilir miyiz
mesleklerimizi nasıl seçiyoruz ne için
çalışıyoruz
tutkuyla mı yapıyoruz işimizi sadece
para kazanmak mı amacımız tutkuyla mı
yaşıyoruz hayatımızı
hayallerimiz var mı
Peki ya bu hayallere ulaşmak için ne
yapıyoruz
benim hayalim bir oyuna dönüştü daha iyi
bir dünya diye Slogana dönüştü
Aslında bu oyun kurmak zaten sevdiğim
bir şey kumaşlarla bir yola çıktım giyin
benim çok ciddiye aldığım bir şey
aslında kendimizi ifadenin çok güçlü bir
aracı olduğunu düşünüyorum
moda kelimesinin kökenine baktığımızda
Aslında latincede fasyo'dan geliyor
yapmak dönüşerek o fashion'a evrilmiş
Dolayısıyla
bir
elbise giyip çıkıyoruz üzerimize ama
aslında kendimize dair dünya görüşümüze
dair bir şey söylüyoruz
filmde Soru sormaya başladım giysilere
dair Nasıl bir kumaştan yapılıyor
Kim kimin emeğiyle nasıl bir süreçten
geçerek üretiliyor
hikayesi var mı
sonrasında
çıkmış oldum
ettiğim dünya için çalışma şeklim iyi
ile buldu bu elbise ile temsil ediliyor
peki
bu yolculuk nasıl başladı
Ben 45 yaşındayım
Ankaralıyım Aslında tasarım eğitimi
almadım
Tekstil sektöründe hiç çalışmadım
ekonomi ve işletme okudum
uzun yıllar mali denetim bütçe planlama
Finans operasyon insan kaynakları gibi
konularda çalıştım
yıllar önce İngiliz pop art sanatçısı
davidophi'nin bir tablosu ile
karşılaşmıştım böyle
dallardan oluşan virajlı Yolları içeren
bir tabloydu ama çok canlı renkli böyle
borular kırmızılar Yeşiller Sarılar
böyle bakıp kayboldu mu hatırlıyorum
yolda kalmak gerektiğinde yolluluğu
renklendirmek ve bazen de değiştirmek
şimdi döndüğümde Benim yolum ne zaman
nerede başlamıştı diye Aslında
çocukluğuma gittiğimde önce stilist
sonra Mimar olmak istemiş Bir küçük
gökdille karşılaşıyorum Ama sen sevmemiş
notları iyiymiş ciddi bir şey okumak
gerekirmiş ekonomi okumuş sonra verelim
İstanbul
'dan anlayacağınız şuankinden bambaşka
bir yola çıkmışım
ama o yolu da sevmiştim çok çalıştım
bayağı çok şey öğrendim faydalı olduğumu
hissettim sektörden sektöre şirketten
şirkete geçerken anne oldum
Belki de yolun renginin değişeceğinin
işareti buydu
oğlum yaptığım bir sebebiyle şey ofise
dönmem gerekiyordu
Tabii ki işte beraberinde ben o yolda
kalmaya devam ettim ama Vicdan azapları
yetişememe halleri vites değiştirdim bir
şekilde o yolda tutundum
ki 4 sene sonra bu sefer kızıma
hamileyken artık bu yolda devam
edemeyeceğine karar verdim
istifa ettim işe ara verdim
Arda
parayı da mutlu ama üretime çalışma
konusunda bir yolu olmayan göknil ile
baş başa kalmıştım
hiç de Mutlu değildim bu durumda ve tam
da almaya bu dönemde başladım
önce içinde bulunduğum duruma dair
sormaya başladım galiba yani neden
annelik ve iş hayatı bu kadar zor
olmalıydı
bu toplumsal cinsiyet kalıplarını Neden
bizi kısıtlıyordu kendimizi koyuyorduk
düşünmeye başladım neyin peşindeydim
şeye mi dönmek istiyordum
yoksa
yeni bir şeye başlamaya Cesaretin var
mıydı
sosyal girişimcilikle Tam da bu dönemde
tanıştım Neyse ki yeni bir şeye deneme
cesareti toplamıştım sosyal giriş
dediler Zaten her biri kendine bir
mesele idaret edilir ve harekete
geçerler
arkadaşımızın fikriydi Biz birkaç kişi
atına ara
ver kadınlar için bir platform üzerine
çalışmaya başladık
Aslında bu bir fırsat eşitliği
projesiydi bir kadın istihdamı
projesiydi
gidip bunu anlatıyor şirketleri kadın
istihdam etmeye davet ediyor Bir yandan
da o işe dönmeye zorlanan kadınlara
güçlendirmeye çalışıyorduk
bu oyunun da adı yeniden biz oldu
yeniden biz dernekleşti benim için oyun
tamamlanmıştı
Ben de özlediğim O ay sonu maaşı belli
kurumsal Hayata geri dönme kararı aldım
Ama bu sefer bir sanat kurumuydu Türkiye
İstanbul'daki ilk Çağdaş Sanat Müzesi
projesiydi benim için yeni bir şeydi
geliştiğim dönüştüğüm bir dönemde 3 yıl
ve bir Koç Vakfında çok severek çalıştım
Bu sırada çocuklar büyüdü Ben 40 yaşıma
gelmiştim ve içinde yine bir şeyler
yapma heyecanı başlamıştı
bir yandan dünyanın bu Aşırı tüketimi
pompalama hali şeylerin değersizleşmesi
canımı sıkıyordu
bir yandan daha iyimser bir bakış
açısıyla o yaratıcı yönle burada bir
nereye tohum atabilirim diye bir yanım
bak diyordu
ve Evet kurumsal hayatı 2 defa bırakıp
girişimciliğe geçmem benim Bu döneme
rast geliyor
olmadı o karar vermekle giyiyi korumam
arasında bir buçuk yıl var
bilmediğimizden korkuyoruz Beynimiz
bildiğimize odaklı bir
marka çarkaya net etmek ne demek hiçbir
fik
rim yok o Demin Size tasvir ettiğim
tabloyu dönünce Devri takvimini Bu sefer
o bir Tepe vardı Ne arkasını
görebiliyordu çok dikti patinaj çekip
duruyordum
Bugün aslında bugünden o güne baktığımda
niye bu kadar başlamakta zorlanmışım
diye
fark ediyorum
ana akım dışında bir iş yap bir şey
yapmak istiyordum Şöyle ki
sezonların trendlerin Black friday'ın
konuşulduğu bir sektörde ben Zamansız
giysilerden bahsetmek istiyordum
kurabileceğimiz Ömürlük giysilerden
bir yandan giysiler bir atık Hızlı
altuket Daha fazla tüket çöpe
döngüsündeyken ben değil giysiyi üretim
hattından
Hani mail ile kültürel değerleri
koruyarak yeni ürün yapmak
heyecanındaydı
bir yandan 0 beden dünyada
özendirilirken ben 34
'ten kutsayacak Bedensiz
kapsayıcı tasarımların peşinde
Bunun neresi moda diyebilirsiniz tabii
aslında işte bu yavaş moda
içeriğine göre döngüsel moda olabildiği
kadar Sürdürülebilir moda pozitif moda
kapsayıcı moda
bütün bu terimler etrafında ben yine
büyük heyecanla bu kurduğum oyunda
çalışmaya başladım ilk koleksiyon 7
tane buluşacaktı
aslında bütün bu hayalini kurduğum
dünyayı anlatabileceğimi düşünüyordum
çok güzel 8 Mart Dünya Emekçi kadınlar
gününde lansman yapmak istedim özellikle
yaptım ama sonra
hepimizin bildiği gibi evde iki yılımız
geçti
ne cekete ne de elbiseye ihtiyacım
benim
o patinaj aldığım eğimli yol var ya o
biraz böyle çamurlandı daha da zorlaştı
ama
o günden bugüne bir hızlı sararsam iki
buçuk yıl giy yoluna devam etti ikinci
koleksiyonun üçüncü koleksiyonunu yaptı
giysiler biraz çeşitlendi
pilav mevsimsiz hala plastiksiz
aslında daha iyi bir dünya demeye
Şimdi bana soruyorlar
kurumsal hayatı bırakmana değdi mi Nasıl
gidiyor işler para kazanabiliyor musun
diye
bir bakma ihtiyacı hissediyorum
Çünkü girişimciliğin bir iş yapmanın
ötesinde bir şey olduğunu düşünüyorum
Türkiye'de kadın girişimci oranına %13'e
geldiğini söylüyorlar yükselmiş o
haliymiş dünyada %34
Atalar
kuruma ve iş yönetme kriterleri üzerinde
bence şu demek
kişileri değiştirme heyecanımız var ya
onu bulmak
içine biraz belki Tutku katmak
hiç var sorumluluk var harekete geçmek
var
girişimci olmak için illa belki sabit
işlerimizi de bırak
Maya Mesela dünyanın dört bir yanında
giderek
seslerini çokça duyduğumuz Barış
çıl yani iklim krizi konusunda
farkındalık yaratan gençlikle
aktivistleri Bence her biri birer
girişimci
aslında bizi bir araya toplayan
girişimci öğrenciler gibi
Dolayısıyla ben
Çok romantik gelebilir Ama hayal etmeye
devam etmeyi önemsiyorum İçimizden Gelen
sesi dinlemeye denemeye
denemeye
iyimser hayalleri önemsiyorum iyimserlik
kavramına da burada değinmek istiyorum
TED konuşmalarında rekor kıran
yazar ve konuşmacı Simon yaptığı
iyimserlik tanımı bana çok uyumuştu
diyor ki sinek
pozitiflik biraz körlük Barındırır diyor
ama iyimserlik günün gerçeğinden hareket
eder acısıyla zorluklarıyla bugünün
farkındalığıyla Geleceğe dair Umut taşır
ve geleceğin parlak olduğuna İnanır
diyor
Bence gerçekten öyle
şimdi bizim Her birimizin kalbini şarkı
söyleten Her neyse onu bulmaya
bir davet etmek isterim sizi neden
önemli bu kadar bu tutku meselesi
insanı heyecanlandıran her gün yatak
Tan güne başlamak için peşine düştüğümüz
şey bence önemli bu tutku ve
girişimcilik konularını çalışan bir
akademisyenin araştırması çıkmıştı
karşıma
diyorlar ki araştırma sonucu
Onun da birkaç şey oluyor
hırsı yükseliyor
bir şey daha oluyor
ama yaratıcı özgüvenli ikna edici
olabiliyoruz
üçüncüsü çok güzel
açıcı
yaptığımız insanlara Hatta ailemize
çevremize Belki biraz abartılı olarak
şartıyla bulaştırabiliyoruz
dönecek olursam
bunun kaynağını merak etmiştim nereden
geldiğini ve o işte soru sorma meraklı
hal var ya o sorular beni yine
çocukluğuma götürdü Ve ben Anneannemde
buldum Aslında
ailedeki zanaatkar üretken kadınlarda
buldum Çünkü her biri İlmek ilmek hayatı
neşeyle zerafetle
azla yetiniyorlardı
dönüştürüyorlardı
iyimser rol modeldi her biri benim için
tığımda Aslında herhalde bana da o kadar
işlemiş ki
parçasında
at bulduğunu görüyorum
tutkumuzun kaynağı Belki bu kadar
geçmişlerde olmaya da bilir Çünkü her
gün kendimize dair bir şeyler
öğreniyoruz
ben şuna inanıyorum
kendimize dair keşif yolculuğumuzda soru
sormak
biraz bakmak Hayal kurmak o insan
hayallerin peşinden gitmek Neyi
değiştirebileceğimize bakmak
buna Devam etmenin gücü ne inanıyorum ve
Belki bir gün sorduğumuz sorulardan bir
tanesinin cevabı Peki bir girişime
dönüşebilir
O yüzden başladığım soruyla da bitirmek
isterim aslında Peki sizin hayalini
kurduğunuz Dünya nasıl bir yer
[Alkış]